today on a superfly episode of next tech
we get a bird's eye view of the dgi
phantom 2 vision plus quadcopter
taking off from shenzhen
aka the silicon valley of china
this drone allows anyone to fly like an
ace
by adding a layer of sophisticated
programming between operator of input
and vehicle response
so signals to the receiver are instantly
translated into algorithms controlling
the individual speeds of each rotor for
changes in velocity
altitude and direction of travel
and should that travel ever take the
quadcopter out of control range it won't
get lost
because the return to home feature
automatically sends it back to its
takeoff point until a connection with
the operator's smart controller is
re-established and if any not so smart
controller accidentally drops their
remote the quadcopter simply hovers in
place
calculating its own position to lock
into a stable altitude
that stability applies to the integrated
camera as well which uses a 3-axis
gimbal to compensate for aircraft motion
because while flying is fun
aerial photography is what the phantom 2
vision plus is really all about
with 14 megapixel stills and hd video
streaming directly to any mobile device
taking photo bombing to a whole new
level
but of course there's always a new next
tech right around the corner and dji's
newest drone the inspire 1 goes further
with dual controllers allowing for more
precise shots as one person flies the
craft while another operates the camera
downward facing ultrasound sensors to
stabilize hover at low altitudes even
indoors and without gps
plus carbon firearms to lift the landing
struts up up and away for unobstructed
360 degree visuals
so the sky's not the limit for your
creativity it's just the beginning
feeling wired yet subscribe